et un deuxième candidat investi par la
république en marche jean-noël barrot 34
ans qui se présente dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
un retour dans les départements pour lui
après quelques années passées aux états
unis et la haute loire où il est
conseiller départemental sous
l'étiquette modem il a été étudiant et
doctorants sur le campus hec de
jouy-en-josas
il lui sera enseignants à la rentrée
prochaine il est au micro de mélanie
poquet il ya deux choses qui me plaisent
beaucoup la première c'est la promesse
d'une recomposition de la vie politique
avec un rassemblement au delà des
postures partisanes qui parfois donne
lieu à des blocages ou des aberrations
en matière de réglementation le projet
que propose emmanuel macron c'est de
dépasser ces clivages pour apporter des
solutions concrètes aux problèmes des
français
la deuxième raison c'est la moralisation
de la vie politique et l'exemplarité qui
sera l'une des premières lois de ce
quinquennat et que j'espère pouvoir
voter si les yvelinoises avesnois
m'accordent leur confiance